[Music]
my name is riotta I'm chairing this
session and it's my great pleasure to
introduce Reuben live in doesn't need an
introduction but let me cover the basics
they've been completed his PhD 1995 at
MIT with Mike Jordan after that he moved
to Toronto to do pass talk with Geoff
Hinton afterwards he has been a founding
member of Gatsby computation on your
science unit from 98 to 2005 and
afterwards he has been professor at
Cambridge University here at the
engineering department
he has been also the founding board
member of the alan turing institute and
most recently has been the chief
scientist at yuba so i'm very excited to
hear about the latest exciting research
happening at both the University and
even on probabilistic machine learning
and yeah great thanks thanks Ryota can
you hear me it's up it's on yeah great
so it's really exciting to be here this
is the second talk I'm giving today the
first one was at 8:30 in the morning and
it was being translated into Mandarin so
every time I said something I had to
wait for somebody to translate and it
made it very difficult to give a lively
talk especially because it was 8:30 in
the morning I've had a few coffees now
so I'm much more awake it's a really
exciting time to be working in machine
learning there is just so much going on
the field is exploding it's crazy I
never imagined that it would be like
this you know 20 years ago or so and I
was starting to get interested in this
and it's been really really exciting
because there's so many applications 20
or 30 years ago there were a lot of
people interested in machine learning
you know we were interested in getting
AI systems working we wanted to get
computers to learn from data but it was
all kind of an academic thing you know
it really didn't seem like it was
anywhere close
to being useful people develop
algorithms just out of scientific
curiosity and test them out on small toy
problems on small computers and so on
and boy have things changed I mean
they're just dramatically different now
we have just to put you know just six
examples that I could fit on one slide
we could put many many more we have
language technologies like speech
recognition and machine translation
question answering and dialogue systems
that are really impacting people's lives
we have computer vision systems that are
doing things that you know we really
didn't imagine we're possible like for
example this famous example from
Stanford of an image captioning system
where for example we're this image that
the computer has never seen before it
produces a caption which says magnin
shirt is playing guitar and that just
seems like magic for computer vision
systems of just a decade ago we have
machine learning that's really impacting
the sciences in terms of areas like
bioinformatics astronomy a lot of
sciences that are becoming very very
data-intensive we have of course the
systems that we've gone grown very
accustomed to in terms of recommender
systems being all driven by machine
learning technologies self-driving cars
something that I've become much more
involved in recently really look like
they're not far from from a reality that
could affect millions of people around
the world and you know just as a sixth
example even the world of finance which
is for many years been resistant to
machine learning is now seeing a huge
number of startups and disruption by
people trying to use machine learning
methods so there have been these
tremendous advances and some of the most
prominent ones are these great examples
from our colleagues down in London in a
deep mind this was obviously a
breakthrough I'm sure all of you know
about where
that really launched deepmind as a
start-up and caught the interest of
Google among other companies where they
managed to get a machine learning system
that combined reinforcement learning
with some deep learning to actually
perform at Atari games and about half of
the Atari games it could play at
superhuman levels which is really pretty
exciting and people didn't think that
that was gonna be that easy then they
moved on to go where now they've they've
actually managed to beat the world
champion at go another kind of landmark
achievement for AI and machine learning
again using heavily ideas from
reinforcement learning and some deep
learning and how many people know what
this is an example of have you seen this
do you know what this is raise your hand
yeah you see this is it's poker so this
was a this was another landmark
achievement maybe you didn't get as much
press but I think it should have gotten
as much press from just a few months ago
this is Libre tus system developed at
Carnegie Mellon University Libre this is
a computer this is how much it's winning
and brains are a bunch of human expert
poker players and this is how much
they're losing against the computer the
humans are not too happy here the
computer really wiped out the human
experts and poker is really interesting
because unlike Atari and go the the
state is very hidden in poker and you
know most of us would think of poker is
a psychological game that involves not
just incomplete information but bluffing
is essential to poker so you can't be a
good poker player unless you're good at
deceiving people and so this was quite
an interesting landmark achievement
recently and there was a team from
Alberta that also similarly had a
breakthrough in poker just just a little
bit after this one so for people coming
into the field of
learning it seems to be a big
complicated mess there's so many
different methods and the methods are
sort of rediscovered by many different
fields and there's sort of these
relationships between the methods that
are not necessarily clear to people and
you know I think it's useful to spend
some time trying to organize the world
of machine learning and think about like
well fundamentally what's going on how
are these methods related to each other
and you know in my worldview everything
is just examples of some fairly simple
concepts what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
just a little bit of time focusing on
neural networks and deep learning just
because it has been really so
revolutionary in the last few years but
I'm also going to spend a lot of my time
talking about my passion which is
probabilistic modeling and Bayesian
methods because again I feel like there
is at least a revolution in the making
there and it's not incompatible with
what we've done in neural networks and
deep learning any questions we can
hopefully take some questions at the end
but if you want to interrupt me feel
free to interrupt as well so let's talk
a little bit about neural nets and deep
learning because as I said they have
been so revolutionary the interesting
thing is that as as probably many of you
know it's not the first time that neural
nets have captured people's attention
neural nets were actually back in the
1980s when I was a teenager that's what
really got me excited about AI neural
nets were going through a big wave of
excitement in the middle to late 80s
when I was an undergraduate and that
wave of excitement kind of died down and
has come back up so what are neural nets
just just to clarify what we mean there
are many different kinds of neural net
but the main kind of neural network that
people work with
right now in the deep learning community
are essentially two nonlinear function
approximator x' okay so a neural net is
a tunable nonlinear function with many
parameters we could call these
parameters theta I like to use the
symbol theta for parameters because
that's often was done in statistics in a
neural model some input-output
relationship that's what I mean by the
nonlinear function in this case maybe
the inputs are X and the outputs are Y
and interestingly neural Nets tend to be
nonlinear both in terms of the
parameters theta and in terms of the
inputs X the simplest kind of neural net
is a very old idea this is the equation
for logistic regression that's basically
a neural net that takes some inputs does
some linear projection of those inputs
and then Maps that into a non-linearity
that turns into a probability of a class
being 1 or 0 for example if you're doing
classification between I don't know
images of cats versus dogs or something
like that
so that's the simplest neural net I
could think of and if you think of most
neural networks essentially what they
are are concatenations of these sorts of
simple primitive operations so a
multi-layer neural net this one only has
one layer multi-layer neural net models
the overall function from X to Y as a
composition of functions those each of
those are the layers in the network and
here is an example of a two layer
version of that which might correspond
to a network that looks like this the
first layer might have elements that
look like this and then you might
linearly combine them in a second layer
to produce the outputs ok in this case
maybe with some Gaussian noise in this
case for classification the details
don't matter you can mix and match these
various forms of neural net
so so these are non-linear tunable
functions well what do you do with them
how do you train them generally almost
all training algorithms for neural
networks can be seen as maximizing
likelihood the likelihood is the
probability of the outputs given the
inputs or maybe a penalized likelihood
if you're trying to avoid overfitting
using some variation on stochastic
gradient descent optimization maximizing
likelihoods is an idea that's about a
hundred years old
in statistics gradient descent methods
are probably one of the simplest forms
of optimization and so boiled down to
its essence a neural network is simply a
nonlinear function approximator combined
with a little bit of very basic
statistics and a little bit of very
basic optimization the interesting thing
is that a lot of statisticians are very
confused about what neural nets are I've
had statisticians come up to me and say
so what's deep learning what's neural
nets and then I explained this to this
to them and they say oh is that it and
then they're like oh well then I'm not
interested and they sort of move on
whereas we kind of know in machine
learning that even though these are
incredibly simple boring things if you
throw enough data at them they'll do
really interesting stuff ok so so that's
what they are and what's been happening
what is different between say the late
80s you know when I was playing on using
neural nets for parsing natural language
and now well there are a whole bunch of
things that are different so one of them
is there was a rebranding exercise and I
applaud the people who managed to pull
this off against all odds' so now we
call a deep learning because people
thought neural networks were kind of old
and passe but deep learning sounded like
something new and deep and so the
rebranding exercise work really well but
there are a whole bunch of new ideas
that were developed some innovations in
terms of architectures in particular
going deeper using more layers using
different activation functions instead
of sigmoid rectified linear z' you know
new ways of regularizing them with
things like dropout RiRi discoveries of
some old and kind of interesting ideas
like LSD aims for time series etc so
there were some innovations and the rate
of innovation just keeps going but
importantly there are just vastly larger
datasets right now really web-scale data
that you can throw these things and
along with that we have vastly larger
compute resources we can actually run
stuff on the cloud with GPUs with you
know people now talk about like hundreds
of cores on a single experiment and
things like that that were unimaginable
a couple of decades ago we also have
much better software tools things that
have really managed to democratize
people's ability to run neural networks
and and reproduce experiments to the
extent that you can be a high school
student with good programming skills and
not really even understand what a
derivative is and you can reproduce
somebody's blog post on neural nets and
think wow cool I'm doing AI right and
that's really what's transformed you
know the inflow of excitement and
interest that's also translated into
vastly increased industry investment
just because these systems have started
to produce exciting results and along
with that there's been massive media
hype okay and the media hype you know
the many ways of explaining it welcome
is when companies start spending
hundreds of millions of dollars on
something the media pays attention if it
looks like it has something to do with
the brain
terminator and stuff like that then the
media go totally crazy and you can
imagine all the stories that come out of
that of course it feeds on itself and
then the next company comes along and
says oh no we're missing out we need to
spend a few hundred million on this as
well right
okay so this is what's happened since
the 80s and 90s and it really has been a
revolution I don't want to I want to be
grounded in reality but I don't want to
minimize from the fact that it has had a
major major impact but it's important
not to get caught up in the fantasy that
AI is solved or something like that if
you actually look at these nonlinear
function approximate errs they have a
lot of limitations and here are a few of
their limitations so one of them is that
neural nets tend to be by and large very
very data hungry humans are pretty good
at learning from a few examples and
neural nets in most cases need large
numbers of examples sometimes millions
of examples they're also extremely
compute-intensive so if you think about
again to use you know our poor primate
brains as an example we operate with
like the power consumption of a light
bulb basically and you know if you look
at a cloud you know full of GPUs or
something that's using massive amounts
of energy and compute to solve fairly
simple problems neural nets and deep
learning systems are actually quite poor
representing uncertainty and this is
something that really bothers me and
I'll talk about in in some detail very
soon
they're also easily fooled by
adversarial examples so how many people
have seen here adversarial examples in
neural nets raise your hand if you've
seen them raise your hand if you haven't
seen them okay I need to account for the
fact that some people just don't like
raising their hands yeah I always have
to ask both questions so as you've seen
adversarial examples are examples that
are either perceptually in India
lingua cheb alum examples from another
example but they gave the neural network
a wildly different output or that the
examples are wildly different from
anything that you've seen in the neural
network is confidently giving you some
output some some response for that so
again has something to do with the
neural nets ability in ability to
represent uncertainty neural nets are
finicky to optimize it's actually quite
hard to do the optimization they're
generally uninterpretable black boxes
they lack in transparency difficult to
trust and actually when when you look at
the examples in industry where things
get deployed if you're just doing
something fairly harmless like maybe
you're just classifying images for fun
then it's okay to be wrong and not know
why you're wrong but if you're doing
something actually rather important like
detecting pedestrians or something like
that in a self-driving car then then the
fact that you have a non transparent
black box system that you can't then
easily debug becomes potentially a
non-starter like you can't even you know
you can't even think of using that
unless you have some reasonable
guarantees and some reasonable ways of
understanding what it's doing and
debugging it so so these are some of the
limitations and what I want to do is I
to actually talk a little bit about
going beyond deep learning and of course
I have my own particular bias there many
ways of going beyond deep learning and
in fact you know to be fair many people
realize all of these limitations and if
you talk to some of the best research
labs in the world they're working on
various aspects of trying to solve these
things but one way of thinking about
going on deep learning is to maybe a
slightly different approach to machine
learning so a lot of people when they
learn
about machine learning they take a
course and the course basically I've
looked at a lot of these syllabuses
around the world and the syllabus
usually looks like sorry I found the
back of this it just looks like a
toolkit of methods so you'll learn about
this you learn about random forests then
you learn about k-means then you learn
about you know back propagation then you
learn about Q learning and it's just a
bag of stuff right there's a little bit
of an attempt at making some fear theory
connections like you you probably want
to have some theoretical analysis of
empirical performance like
generalization error and so on of
various different methods the framework
that I'm going to talk about which you
know I'm quite in love with although it
has its own limitations is thinking
about machine learning as have a science
of learning models from data and so most
things can be put under that rubric not
everything but the idea is that there is
sort of like a an overarching scientific
framework for doing machine learning and
the details of the algorithms are just
that they're details they matter but you
kind of look at the bigger picture and
the bigger framework so what do I mean
by learning from data and what do I mean
by modeling in particular so here is the
sort of view of machine learning as
probabilistic modeling well let's step
back and ask ourselves what is a model
okay and the term model is used in many
many different fields it means different
things to different people but one way
of thinking about models is a model is a
description of possible data you could
observe from a system okay so the way
you tell you know you might also be an
understandable interpretable or
something like that like a model in the
sciences or something like that or an
economic model or you know
model in biology and so on all these the
term model gets used a lot but I think
ultimately if the model can't make some
claims about potential data then it's
very hard to know if it's a good model
or not at some point you have to ground
the model in data and not the data that
you had before because very easy to say
oh that my model fits my old data
perfectly the model should say something
about data you haven't observed yet
now because of that modeling is
intimately tied to the concept of
uncertainty so to make any claims about
data we haven't observed yet we have to
you know be honest about our uncertainty
in terms of the data we haven't observed
yet like you can't have for example a
weather forecasting model that gives you
a precise temperature for tomorrow
without telling you what its uncertainty
is it just doesn't make much sense so
we're gonna use the mathematics of
probability theory to express all forms
of uncertainty and noise associated with
our model and then it turns out that
that same mathematical framework can be
used to do inferences about unknown
quantities adapt our models make
predictions and learn from data and all
of this used to be called probability
you know this part used to maybe
sometimes he called inverse probability
until early in the 20th century when
Fischer who's a classical sort of one of
the founders of classical statistics
said oh that probability inverse
probability that's what you're just
followers of Thomas Bayes you're
Bayesian sand he coined actually he
coined the term Bayesian as they're like
a derogatory term to distinguish himself
because he was creating a new view on
statistics so we could call it inverse
probability if we want to go back in
time and the framework basically boils
down to a very very simple set of
concepts so in the world of
probabilistic modeling
you know Bayesian machine learning and
so on there are only two kinds of things
there are stuff you observe or measure
that's what you call data and then
there's everything else everything else
is stuff that you didn't measure so
necessarily you can you have to be
uncertain about the stuff you didn't
measure and we're going to use the
mathematics of probability theory to
represent all forms of uncertainty just
like we use calculus to represent rates
of change probability theories of
mathematics of uncertainty and actually
don't like the term randomness because
you know it connotes some something
weird actually I don't believe much is
random for example I can be uncertain
about how many people there are in this
room right I'm certainly uncertain about
that but the number of people in this
room is not random in a usual colloquial
sense of the world world word and when I
look at this room that's data that my
brain gets about the number of people
here my brain is trying to process that
and maybe you know I'm guessing maybe
they're between I don't know 40 and 90
people in this room probably more than
40 I don't know maybe between 50 and 90
all right so how do I represent that
uncertainty well the idea and problem
stick modeling is use probability
distributions for all forms of
uncertainty okay so you use probability
distributions for certainty you get data
for example I'm looking and I might
collect more data let me let's say I
start counting that's just collecting
more data and at some point my
uncertainty collapses learning is the
process of going from a state of
knowledge before observing the data
that's the prior to a state of knowledge
after observing the data and the process
by which you go through that is a very
simple process you take your prior which
is a distribution over you're on certain
quantities or hypotheses you multiply it
by the likelihood we
is a probability of the observed data
for any one of your hypotheses like
number of people in the room would be
various hypotheses I could entertain you
multiply the prior by the likelihood you
renormalize summing over all the
hypotheses you are willing to consider
and then you get the posterior
distribution over hypotheses given data
it's as straightforward as that and the
beauty of this is that we can use this
as a unifying principle for a lot of
machine learning not necessarily for the
parts of machine learning that involve
decision making like reinforcement
learning that involves an additional
thing that we need to add on top of this
Bayesian framework but for most of the
rest of machine learning we can actually
use this to understand what's going on
so it turns out actually Bayes rule
isn't even a fundamental rule Bayes rule
is a corollary of to even simpler rules
from probability theory the sum rule in
the product rule and here the sum rule
the product rule written out in a boring
form as you might find in a textbook
some rule says that the probability of
some variable is the sum or integral if
that other variable is continuous over
some other variable Y of the joint
probability and the product rule says
that the joint probability of two
variables X or not Y can be factored
into this marginal probability of x
times the conditional probability of Y
given X or the other way around basic
rules you might learn about in a
textbook if we take these X's and Y's
and we replace them by things that we
might actually be interested in like D
for data theta for parameters of a model
and then condition everything on em
which might be like the model class that
we are currently considering then we get
a single equation this is now Bayes rule
that defines learning from data for
parameters and it says well you have a
model with some parameters before
observing the data you have a prior
which represents your uncertainty about
what those parameters could be then you
observe the data so you multiply the
prior by this likelihood term and then
you renormalize it with this interesting
quantity called the marginal likelihood
and that gives you the posterior over
parameters given the data it's very
straightforward if you had to make
predictions then probability theory
tells you that to predict any unknown
quantity call that unknown quantity x
given the data that you've observed then
the sum and product rule tell you
there's only one and only one way of
doing prediction and that is average or
integrate the predictions for different
parameter values weighted by this
posterior probability of a parameter
values that you've considered in the
equation above
so prediction in the Bayesian framework
is naturally an ensemble intent
predictors and model comparison is
essentially just the application of
Bayes rule at a level slightly higher up
from parameters to a level of models
like for example are there I don't know
three or four clusters in the data or
should I have you know ten or twenty
hidden units these are all modeling
questions right and you could answer
them in principle using this framework
so any questions about that
yeah so there so the framework I've
talked about talks about inference from
data which is learn you know think about
that as as knowledge acquisition or
learning from data reinforcement
learning falls into decision theory so
actually it's not incompatible it's just
that it's a part so there's Bayesian
inference and there's Bayesian decision
Theory Bayesian decision theory says
once I've inferred everything I'm
interested in now maybe there is a loss
function
which tells me what the law says for
various different states of the world
and I should take actions that minimize
my expected loss and that's
reinforcement learning loss reward is
the same thing it's not immediate reward
you're looking at long-term reward
so it's bayesian sequential decision
theory would be how we would think about
any sequential decision problem as in
reinforcement learning and it's nothing
new been around for 60 years at least
yeah so what we're trying to learn is
the posterior of the parameters yeah is
it considered is it assumed
so usually this term here the likelihood
is something that we assume is known but
the funny thing is that actually we
shouldn't really necessarily assume that
the likelihood function is even known
maybe the likelihood function has some
parameters that you have to infer but if
you could consider a family of
likelihood functions you can just say
that they're just extra parameters you
have to infer from data that allow you
to choose between different likelihood
functions it gets a little bit subtle
but just like in basically in almost all
of statistics and also machine learning
people assume that the likelihood or the
loss function is given to you and then
they try to optimize it but I actually
think your question is really insightful
because in most of those cases that's
the weak point in the model that thing
was an assumption everything is an
assumption the only thing that's not an
assumption is the data okay everything
else is an assumption and so from the
Bayesian point of view what we really
should be doing is questioning every
assumption and not just questioning the
assumptions but actually doing something
about that you know trying to improve on
those assumptions so loss functions and
likelihoods are also assumption okay let
me move on so why should we care about
this whole framework I mean deep
learning has been so spectacularly
successful that you know you would think
well we can forget about all this
probability theory and just you know run
whatever atom on my tensorflow model and
I'll be fine or whatever
well here's at least one of the reasons
I care there two of the reasons I care
actually so one of them is we really
want I think we really want calibrated
models where the prediction
uncertainties are something we can
believe in so and it's not just kind of
a nice thing I think it's actually a
necessary thing we really need machine
learning systems that know when they
don't know that if they're given
new input they'll tell you whoa I don't
know what the answer is we don't want
them to be confidently making stupid
mistakes if they're confidently making
stupid mistakes
they'll be fine in the lab they'll never
get deployed in the real world the other
thing is that this spring work actually
gives us a really nice way of doing
automatic model control and structure
learning so learning the structure of
models automatically from data and
that's really beautiful because one of
the things that annoys me the most about
current machine learning practice is
that people just comp with stuff out of
thin air right and it's just it's just
like you know it's like a cottage
industry of people randomly inventing
stuff testing it out a couple times and
then saying oh this works better than
other things and that's just it's just
not a systematic science it's a
hodgepodge it's really disappointing
and we would like to make it a
systematic science and actually the way
to make it a systematic science is get
the human out of the loop I mean you
know maybe make the human do other
things or kind of oversee things but the
search over models should be something
that's done by a computer systematically
and this framework gives us a nice way
of doing that um so just to be concrete
about you know what does it mean to be
Bayesian here is here it is in the
context of a neural network so in the
context of a neural network the what are
the sources of uncertainty well the
parameters are uncertain right because
you don't know what the parameters are
and actually the structure is uncertain
people haven't really dealt with
structure uncertainty but but you know
in an ideal world I would love to see
both parameter and structure uncertainty
dealt with in a neural network it just
might not be very practical but you know
that's why I said in an ideal world and
actually the sort of world of neural
networks and deep learning and the world
of Bayesian
machine learning are not in any sort of
conflict they're actually quite
compatible the two kind of live in
different spaces so neural networks are
a kind of model some kind of function
approximator and bayesian methods are
just a framework for thinking about
learning so people for a couple of
decades at least have thought about
applying bayesian methods to neural
networks and so here are some examples
going back to the early 90s people like
David McKay rat for neal geoff hinton
worked on this even yong the kuhn worked
on this even earlier even though he
didn't realize he was doing this he'll
admit to that you know you sort of like
analyzed from a physics perspective but
it turned out he was doing Bayes rule on
neural network weights in the in the
late 80s you itay who's sitting here has
a really nice paper on stochastic
gradient launch of and dynamics this is
a really beautiful idea where you can
take stochastic gradient descent SGD add
noise to it in a particular way and show
that it approximates actually doing
Bayesian learning in neural network
parameters and some of our work in in
the machine learning group in Cambridge
has also been kind of developing better
ways of doing Bayesian neural networks
Bayes in deep learning we had a workshop
at nips which was great fun last year we
are trying to have another one this year
and here's an example of why we might
care like if you have some data and
you're fitting a neural network to some
input-output data where you have data
you can afford to be confident but where
you don't have data what you really want
is something that shows a great deal of
uncertainty so that's sort of the ideal
thing that we want so when do we need
probabilities just to kind of summarize
some of the the threads of thinking I've
described I think we need probabilities
when we want to really carefully
represent uncertainty so this includes
things like forecasting decision-making
you know usually
decisions are made on the basis of
future consequences of actions so we
need to have a representation of the
consequences of our actions when we're
learning from limited noisy or missing
data for example in medical domains this
is very very useful if we're doing
complex personalised modeling like an
advertising or again in medicine all
data compression methods are basically
probabilistic models either implicitly
or explicitly and for automating this
sort of scientific approach to modeling
this is quite useful
so now as Ryota mentioned I'm I'm sort
of leading ubers AI research right now
and so why would a company like uber
care about something like probabilistic
modeling well it turns out that actually
it's it's everywhere that we look so in
the research lab that I'm trying to
build at uber we have people with deep
learning expertise we have people with
reinforcement learning and probably
sleek modeling expertise and so on
they're a bunch of different communities
in there but when we look around there
are actually a huge number of very clear
probabilistic modeling problems so if
you look at the kinds of data the kinds
of modeling that we have to do to
optimize the service that we provide
this involves understanding the spatial
temporal dynamics and being able to
forecast that for both drivers which is
the supply and riders which is the
demand side we have to be able to model
eta how long it takes for food or a
person or package to get from A to B we
use models in all of our like
forecasting and planning we're modeling
cities were modeling traffic it's all
about modeling stuff and these are
complicated systems to model and so we
can use combinations of deep learning as
sort of function approximator z' and
probabilistic modeling to build
sophisticated forecasting models and
then to
optimize the system on top of that so
the service is just better for everybody
and that is I said all of that and I'm
not even talking about self-driving cars
which is a whole nother there you know
several hundred people working on
self-driving cars and uber and and there
are many many modeling problems as well
in that domain and of course we're also
trying to build personal aviation
service which I'm sure will come with
his modeling problems this is like by
2020 we have committed to doing trials
in Dubai and Dallas of what you and I
would all call flying cars but the guys
who run that or uber hate the term
flying cars because they don't actually
drive on the road they're sort of like
giant drones that you get into and you
fly from A to B so watch out in the next
few years but this is part of what we're
also trying to do and again although
initially the vertical takeoff and
landing vehicles will be piloted
eventually these will be autonomous
electrical vehicles so all the same
sorts of you know inference perception
and modeling problems that occur in the
self-driving domain will also occur in
the flying domain so that's it for the
uber stuff so for the the rest of the
time that I have a few few more minutes
what I want to do is I want to talk
about kind of three areas that I think
are really exciting at the cutting edge
of machine learning in AI right now and
these are areas that my my group and
myself are working on that we're very
excited about I've already talked a
little bit about Bayesian deep learning
I'm not going to talk much more about
that I'm basically going to talk about
probabilistic programming the automatic
statistician and Bayes in optimization
very briefly on each of those so let's
start with public programming
the idea of Papa sick programming is all
this probabilistic modeling stuff is
nice but it's really time consuming to
define a promising model and then derive
an inference algorithm and implement the
inference algorithm and so on and it's
not just time-consuming but it's
incredibly error-prone the that is comes
in the form of this field of
probabilistic programming and the idea
is a two-part idea one of them is
instead of defining your model as a
bunch of equations or something like
that or a graphical model a diagram in a
paper define your model as a computer
program okay the computer program that
can generate data now it could be a
conditional data generator like if
you're trying to generate Y as a
function of X the program could take an
X and produce possible Y's that's a
conditional program or it could be a
generative model of like X like if
you're trying to build a generative
model for language or speech or
something like that it could generate
the whole signal for you in any case
it's a computer program and that idea is
obviously very old like we have
simulators many many fields of science
and engineering have relied on
simulators which are computer programs
for their models the really interesting
bit of promising programming is this
second part which is given your model
defined as a simulator we can actually
define a universal inference engine and
that is a system that will basically do
Bayes rule on computer programs so what
does that mean actually in practice what
that means is I have a simulator for
potential data which has a bunch of
random variables in it but now I have
some real data that's the data I've
actually observed and what I'd like to
do is I would like to figure out what
are the plausible hidden variables or
random variables in my simulator that
are consistent with my real data if I
can do that that's actually solving
Bayes rule on my computer program
I'm gonna condition well let's think
about this way we're all used to running
computer programs in the forward
direction you give them inputs and they
produce outputs this is like thinking
about running them in a backward
direction given that I know what the
outputs are that was the data what are
the calls to the random number generator
that are consistent with those outputs
that's the basic concept and this sounds
kind of like magic but it's actually
possible and there have been a whole
bunch of systems here around that have
developed on this idea and I want to
call out in particular a system that was
developed at Microsoft Research in
particular in this lab here which was
really way ahead of his time over ten
years ago in Fernet was really like the
most powerful promising programming
language for scalable modeling but by
now we have a whole bunch of different
languages that have been developed
including cheering which is the language
developed in my group and I'll show you
some examples of that and then under the
hood what's happening is that we have a
whole bunch of inference algorithms
these are methods that can be used to
figure out what those hidden variables
are given the data and these are various
forms of Markov chain Monte Carlo
variational inference or particle
filtering etc here's an example from the
programming language cheering and maybe
what I'll do is up the video which is
just easier to explain I think
okay so
okay I guess let's green alright so if
you're familiar with how many people
know what a hidden Markov model is raise
your hand if you know it okay good
almost almost everybody so here is a
hidden Markov model defined in this
public programming language tearing the
the main things that are here are this
model construct Turing is based on Julia
and kind of nice modern scientific
programming language which is meant to
be kind of a replacement for MATLAB and
are and everything else
and here is an hmm defined and the the
main thing to notice is this like little
tilde character which is drawn from so
this defines s is drawn from a
categorical distribution either the
states of aden markov model and these
are the outputs like a normal drawn from
a normal distribution this I would argue
is about as natural and compact a
representation of an hmm as I would
imagine having in a programming language
so it's the surface form is really nice
inference is like this you say I'm going
to do sampling on my hmm and I'm going
to use particle Gibbs with some
parameters so this is a call to the
inference algorithm you don't have to
implement that implement that and then
what happens is you run this and a few
minutes later it actually has done it
for instance it's just a visualization
of the hidden States over time which is
a bit boring they're jumping around a
little bit I'll just show another
example maybe okay so here is an example
of here's another example of a hidden
Markov model but what this is it's a
Bayesian hidden Markov model Bayesian
hidden Markov model by this we mean a
hidden Markov model where we're actually
representing the uncertainty in the
transition matrix and in the parameters
of the emission model so we just
add a couple of extra four extra lines
to this to turn our previous code into a
Bayesian hmm
and again we can do inference on that in
this case it's a combination of
hamiltonian Montecarlo and particle
Gibbs all wrapped into an outer loop of
inference with Gibbs and this is just
the visualization of inference on that
and now it has some uncertainty about
where the means of the different
observations are and that's shown here
okay and maybe I'll show one last one so
this is just defining a mixture of
categoricals let's jump ahead this is
defining latent purush lay allocation
again you know the code for late and
dearly a location is really pretty
straightforward so it's sort of knights
in abstract that way okay
okay so that was a promise like
programming let me move on Oh question
yeah so the restriction is on stuff that
we've implemented okay
and so there are a few algorithms we've
implemented under the hood and we are
you know my team is implementing some
other ones different promise like
programming languages have different
things that people have implemented so
we've done various versions of particle
filtering MCMC with hamiltonian monte
carlo nots we're trying to reproduce
what stan does and benchmark against
that I mean completely honestly it's a
very nice framework cuz it's all
naturally embedded in julia it's not as
fast this language like Stan because
that's actually optimized for finite
models whereas we can actually deal with
the broader class of models and we're
but we're working on making it all much
more efficient and scalable and this is
what's going on actually interestingly I
have an effort like this going on at
Cambridge and the uber AI labs Noah
Goodman who's one of the pioneers of
policy programming is working at uber
now and we're developing a scalable kind
of industry strength policy programming
language at uber as well in terms of
data yeah I mean the target that we have
is as scalable as deep learning
frameworks okay okay
so parallelizable run on GPUs etc and in
fact we're piggybacking on top of deep
learning kind of frameworks that exist
in adding a layer of probablistic
programming to them yeah
learning parameters that are actually
related to each other they might
conflict with each other does that then
make it not you need to learn covariance
makers as well or yeah Miri if you have
a model with many parameters the mean
the posterior the parameters will be
correlated even if in the prior they're
not correlated in practice what people
do is either they ignore that which is
an approximation or they use a sampling
method where you can infer the
correlation from the samples let me move
on because I only have a mean weight
I've been taking some questions along
the way but I want to leave at least a
couple of minutes for questions at the
end as well I'm gonna move on to very
quickly talk about the the two other
ideas amazing optimization the idea
Bayesian optimization is that we want to
do global optimization of some black box
functions that are expensive to evaluate
so this is the basic idea
find the Arg max of f of X there's a
function of X very simple idea but the
key thing is what if evaluating f of X
costs quite a lot of time or money or
you know energy or whatever it is what
do you do then well the right thing to
do then is you treat this as a problem
in sequential decision-making and you
model the uncertainty that you have in
the function f to figure out what the
optimal actions are and this has just a
huge number of applications and it's
important to think beyond the little
world of machine learning to think about
all of the other aspects of you know
science and engineering that might
involve optimizing something anywhere we
can optimize something we can actually
base an optimization I think if certain
criteria hold one of the this is just
amazing optimization in nutshell the
thing that drives it is you're making
decisions about where to evaluate the
function this is the function let's say
you're uncertain about the function
that's why it's so
with the you know shaded region you've
evaluated some data this is why you're
being bayesian you're actually trying to
represent the uncertainty that you have
in your function and then based on that
uncertainty what you have is something
called an acquisition function which is
telling you where it's best to evaluate
your function next it's sort of trading
off exploration exploitation because
it's a decision-making problem and so
where is this useful I've already said I
actually think it's useful to think
about any optimization problems and
particularly if evaluating the function
is expensive if you're valuating
derivatives is hard or impossible if
there is noise in the function
evaluations or there may be noisy
constraints or there is prior
information about the function that you
might want to use an optimization or if
you need to optimize many similar
functions so in all of these contexts
actually it helps to think about things
in terms of Bayesian optimization the
last thing I want to talk about is very
very quickly this idea of the automatic
statistician and the idea here is that
we have a lot of data but we don't have
enough data scientists so what can we do
well we can superpower the data
scientists or we can replace the data
scientists and that's really the idea of
building systems that automate model
discovery from data and I see Ryota
standing up sort of that's what happens
when you take questions you know an
already too long to talk so no no it's
fine we can sort of run through it I
just want to show maybe I'll run to the
I'll just show you the video which takes
over a couple minutes so the system
basically takes raw data in the form of
a table it searches over good models
they finds a good model and then it
turns that model into a report that
provides patterns in the data to human
user and the key thing is that this is
like really meant to be the opposite of
a black box you really want a
transparent box you want the computer to
explain in English
found in the data to you so here is just
a demo of the automatic statistician
running on a classic tiny data set
called iris so you load up the data
it says your report is being prepared
this is the report that it prepares it's
actually found it's evaluated actually
Oh what happened there
what happened was that the report was
actually a dynamic object so it keeps
thinking about models and it keeps
updating the report which is a webpage
now the report is sort of finished and
this is a very basic version where it's
doing some visualizations what it
decided was that the best model for
explaining what's in the data is to
assume that there are just three
clusters in the data which actually if
you know iris is not a bad assumption
sort of discover that on its own and
then it produces a whole bunch of
visualizations that show you that
there's my purposes of three clusters in
the data okay so I think I'm now
basically ready to jump to the
conclusions that's just the automatic
statistician we've done it for
classification as well and I want to
conclude by saying a lot of the the
things I've described in this talk are
in this review paper that I'm happy if
you can't get it online to share with
people and I wanted to thank a whole
bunch of collaborators collaborators
[Applause]